So what happens if I go to Eretz
Yisrael and I follow the psak of the
Beit Yosef, which is also the psak of
the Mishnah Berurah, which was also the psak
of the Arukh HaShulchan? It was the psak
of the consensus for many, many years until
recently when it became more popular to follow
the psak of the Chakham Tzvi, who says
you only keep one day when you're visiting
Eretz Yisrael. Let's say I'm of the opinion
that I should be keeping two days of
Yom Tov in Eretz Yisrael because I'm legitimately
a Ben Chutz LaAretz. I'm not somebody who
counts myself as a Ben Eretz Yisrael as
much as I would want to be there
right now. The bottom line is I'm not.
So the question would become: Would I be
allowed to ask someone who lives in Eretz
Yisrael legitimately, would I be allowed to ask
them to do melakhah for me on Yom
Tov Sheni? Or is that considered similar to
Amira LeNokhri? The Shulchan Arukh says the same
way Amira LeNokhri is not permissible on Shabbos
or Yom Tov, just like we're not allowed
to ask a non-Jew on Shabbos or Yom
Tov to do anything for us, so too
we are not allowed to ask on Yom
Tov Sheni. Yom Tov Sheni is just as
serious almost as a regular day of Yom
Tov. Even though it's only rabbinic, even though
it's only miderabbanan, the prohibition of Amira LeNokhri
applies equally on Yom Tov Rishon as it
does on Yom Tov Sheni. So would it
be the same to ask a Jew who
is not observing Yom Tov? That's a strange
case. Would I be allowed to ask a
Jew who's not observing Yom Tov to do
something for me? What would be another application
of that? Anybody know? Forget about Yom Tov
Sheni for a minute. Let's say in the
summer months when I'm mekabel Shabbos early. So
I'm mekabel Shabbos at 5:30 but Shabbos really
doesn't come in until 7:45. So I'm in
a position where I'm able to be mekabel
Shabbos early but there are many of my
neighbors and friends who come home later from
work, have younger children, whatever it is, they're
going to be mekabbel Shabbos at the zman
and not early. So the question is during
that interim period, if let's say I come
home from shul and I already davened Friday
night, I said Mizmor Shir, I was mekabbel
Shabbos upon myself earlier than I had to,
and now I realize I forgot to turn
on the air conditioner, I forgot to turn
on the lights, would I be allowed to
ask a neighbor to do that for me
when that neighbor has not yet accepted Shabbos
upon him or herself? That's a similar kind
of question. It gets a little bit more
complicated. Let's say on Shabbos I do not
open bottles, right? There's a big machlokes whether
you're allowed to open bottles on Shabbos not
so clear. Let's say my family minhag is
that you're not allowed to open bottles. What's
the issue? Big question. Some say it might
be makeh bepatish, whatever. It may be a
violation of a melakhah. It's not clear exactly
what it is, but it's a big discussion.
Some say it's totally fine, some say it's
totally not. So if you're from the group
of people who say that you're not allowed
to, but I have someone at my table
who legitimately follows their psak, which is that
they are allowed to, would I be allowed
to ask that person to open the bottle
for me? Or let's say for example if
I'm part of a Chassidish community where they
end Shabbos with the zman of Rabbeinu Tam
and they keep Shabbos very late and they
have a long Shalosh Seudos. And now it's
an hour and a half after Shabbos, is
over but they're still going. Would I be
allowed to ask that person to do something
for me when I, as a person who's
not a member of the community, has already
ended Shabbos and said Havdalah? All of those
are very important questions and I don't think
the answer is going to be the same
in all of those cases. Yeah, I think
this is different. I know someone in my
community who, like we have a person there
who's a Ben-Torah, doesn't follow eruv, so like
his mom will carry his tallis. Aha, so
that's a very interesting story you raised, because
there's a story about Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach
that there was a boy in Yerushalayim who
lived in Shaarei Chesed who decided for himself
that he was not going to use the
eruv. So one Shabbos Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach
notices that the boy is walking down the
street together with his father. His father was
in his 70s, was holding a big stack
of chairs, and the son is walking right
next to him. So Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach
stops him in the street and he says:
What's going on? Your father's 70 years old,
you're 25. How come your father's carrying the
stack of chairs? He says: Well we have
a kiddush down the block and they needed
extra chairs so we went home, we got
some chairs. So Rav Shlomo Zalman said: No,
I'm not asking where you're going with the
chairs. I'm asking why are you allowing your
father to carry the chairs instead of you?
And he said: Well I don't carry in
the eruv. So he said: Because you decided
you want to be machmir and not carry
in the eruv, you think you're allowed to
violate kibbud av va'em and make your father
schlepp the chairs for you? So it's a
difficult balance. And by the way, that's something
that you have to think about in general:
Every chumra that you take upon yourself, chumras
are very nice, but every chumra that you
take upon yourself has a price that you're
going to have to pay for it. That's
the way it is in life. There's a
trade-off, right? So let's say for example, a
chumra that we're familiar with is the Gemara
says in Hilchos Niddah, in Maseches Niddah, that
women today took upon themselves that they are
more machmir in Hilchos Niddah than they were
in the days of the Mishnah. They wait
longer than they otherwise would have had to.
Whatever, it's a you'll get there when you
get there, but that's that's the halakhah. We
are machmir way, way beyond what the Torah
expects us to do. Now, you'll say it's
beautiful, taharas hamishpacha, it's so nice, it brings
kedushah into your house, it's wonderful. Yeah, but
you're also paying a price for that. What
price are you paying? What price are you
paying? There's also a mitzvah for a husband
and wife to be married to each other
and to be interacting with one another and
to be having responsibilities toward one another in
physical ways, so you're again, the Gemara assumes
that that's a fair trade-off, but understand that
every chumra that is instituted always has a
price that you have to pay on the
other side and you really have to think
carefully is this really worthwhile? Is this something
that is a price that is worthy of
paying for the chumra that I want to
do? So that's an important question. So here
the question begins let's say by Shabbos When
I'm mekabbel Shabbos early would I be allowed
to ask somebody who has not yet accepted
Shabbos to do a melacha on my behalf?
I come home from shul Friday night, I
see that the lights are not on, the
air conditioner is not set. Would I be
allowed to ask my neighbor when it's still
light outside to then come into my home
and do everything that needs to be done?
Good question. Okay. So we go to a
Gemara Maseches Shabbos. The Gemara says that I'm
not allowed to hire workers to do work
for me on Shabbos. Now what does that
mean? It means if I have a field
and I need people to work the field,
I'm not allowed to have people work the
field. It also means, says the Gemara, that
I'm not allowed to have someone if let's
say I have a field in Kansas. Now
I'm not going to have anybody work the
field but I'm afraid, I live in New
York and I'm not going to be there
for Shabbos so I'm concerned that maybe someone
is going to come steal all my produce
on Shabbos. so I need to have somebody
watching over the field. Says the Gemara you're
not allowed to have a worker. That's also
called work. But the Gemara says I'm allowed
to make a deal with another Jew who
happens to live in Kansas right near my
field. What's the deal? He owns a piece
of property in New York right near my
house. I own a piece of property in
Kansas right near his house. I'm allowed to
say to him shmor li ve'eshmor lach. You
watch over my field over Shabbos, I'll watch
over your piece of property here in New
York over Shabbos and everybody will be fine.
I'm not paying you, you're not paying me,
we're each doing each other a favor that's
mutually beneficial. So the Gemara says that that
would be permissible. Now why is that permissible?
In the end of the day he's doing
the work for you. Along comes the Rashba,
the Rashba is one of the great Rishonim,
and the Rashba says that the reason for
that is because kelomar af al pi shehu
eino yachol lelech lesham, even though I'm in
New York right now and I'm unable to
be in Kansas, I wouldn't be able to
walk there on Shabbos, it's too far, it's
out of the techum, says the Rashba, since
theoretically I would be able to figure out
a way to be there, therefore it's not
considered to be a problem because I myself
could have figured out a way to be
there. Had I set up a hut right
next to my field, I would have been
able to watch it myself. Since I could
have done it myself theoretically, I'm allowed to
have someone else doing it. Says the Rashba,
and from here we learn de-Yisrael she-kibel alav
Shabbos kodem she-chashecha, a Jew that accepts Shabbos
early before it's dark outside, mutar lomar le-Yisrael
chaveiro la'asos lo melacha plonis. I'm allowed to
go to my friend who has not yet
accepted Shabbos, and I'm allowed to ask that
person to do a melacha for me. Why?
Why? What's the logic? Finish off the sentence.
How is that similar to the case of
the Gemara? Was
I not clear? The end of the sentence
is because I would have had the opportunity,
had I chosen not to accept Shabbos early,
I could have done melacha myself. So I
made a decision this week that I want
to keep Shabbos early, but since theoretically I
could have done the melacha myself, therefore I'm
allowed to ask a Jew to do the
melacha who hasn't yet accepted Shabbos which is
similar, says the Rashba, to that case of
the Gemara where had I set up shop
in Kansas I would have been able to
watch over my field myself and therefore I'm
allowed to ask the person who's a resident
there to watch over it for me. That's
the association that he makes. The Ran, one
of the other Rishonim, disagrees, but the Shulchan
Aruch accepts the opinion of the Rashba. And
he says exactly what the Rashba says, that
if I accept Shabbos early I'd be allowed
to then go ahead and ask somebody, if
I come home and I see the lights
are not on, I'd be allowed to ask
somebody to come and do the melacha on
my behalf because they have not yet accepted
Shabbos, and that would be acceptable. A lot
to talk about in that Rashba, a lot
to understand, but just on a very basic
simple level the Shulchan Aruch quotes the Rashba
that that would be permissible. So let me
give you a fascinating extension that the Pri
Megadim writes in Shulchan Aruch. Pri Megadim says,
a kohen is not allowed to go into
a cemetery. Not only is he not allowed
to go into a cemetery, he's not allowed
to go into a house that has a
dead body in it either. Right? It's a
big question whether a kohen is allowed to
visit a hospital. Every hospital has dead bodies
unfortunately every day. So is a kohen allowed
to go into a hospital where he knows
that by entering the building he's probably going
to come not in contact with a dead
body, but somewhere under the roof of the
building there's going to be a dead body.
These are all questions you have to think
about, but now you'll say you don't have
to think about them, why? Why? Because even
if you are from a family of kohanim,
there's no prohibition on women to become tamei,
right? Female kohanim, any kohanim in the room?
No? Oh, so you're allowed to go to
a cemetery. You shouldn't have to, but you're
allowed to go to a cemetery. The prohibition
is only on male Kohanim. So you'll say,
so why am I even mentioning this about
the hospital? You know why? Im yirtzeh Hashem,
someday you're going to be pregnant. Im yirtzeh
Hashem, it's possible that you're going to be
pregnant with a boy. My wife did it
six times with boys. We specialize in boys.
So this is a big shayla. If you
are pregnant with a boy, are you allowed
to go to a cemetery or is that
considered as if you are bringing a male
Kohein into a cemetery? How do you like
that? Interesting. That is a question. So
I get the question all the time from
pregnant women who are not from a family
of Kohanim. Am I allowed to go to
a funeral, am I allowed to go to
a cemetery? The answer to that is yes.
Some say al pi Kabbalah, whatever it is,
but the halacha says it's absolutely permissible for
a woman who is pregnant to go to
a cemetery or to attend a levayah, there's
no problem at all. What they don't know
to ask is if I am married to
a Kohein and the child that I am
now pregnant with is a boy, am I
allowed to go to a cemetery? That is
a real serious question. That is a major
shayla that is discussed in the Shach and
all the other poskim. It's a big big
shayla, not for now, but that's the shayla.
So we know that a Kohein, a male
Kohein, is not allowed to go and come
in contact with a dead body. Says the
Pri Megadim, would a Kohein be allowed to
ask somebody, let's say I have my suitcase
that got stuck in somebody's house and now
there's a dead body in the house, but
I need the suitcase, I gotta go to
the airport, so what do I do? Of
course I can't go in the house myself.
Can I ask somebody else to go in
the house for me and take it out
on my behalf? So the Pri Megadim writes
as follows, Lefi zeh, mutar lekohein lomar leYisrael
leilech lemakom tumat meis ulehavi lo misham heftzo.
I'm allowed to go in, I'm sorry, I
can't go in myself, and I'm allowed to
instruct a Kohein to go in for me.
And he learns that from this halacha that
the Shulchan Aruch says. Just like the Shulchan
Aruch says, when I was not mekabbel Shabbos
but you were, I'm allowed to ask you
to do some activity for me that I
myself am not allowed to do, so too
here, he says, if a Kohein is going
to be instructed to go in and get
the Kohein's suitcase from the house that has
a dead body in it, that would be
something that is permissible because he sees that
as an extension of this halacha. What about
in the other direction? I'll take your question
in a minute. Says the Rama, what about
in the other direction? Like we said, you're
from a Hasidish community and you keep Rabbeinu
Tam and even beyond Rabbeinu Tam, your Shalosh
Seudos goes for another two hours after Shabbos
is over. Many of the communities do that,
right? So what happens in that interim period?
If you're from my community, you've made Havdalah,
the second Shabbos is over. Now down the
block we have Hasidim who are having Shalosh
Seudos and the lights go out. Can they
call me over and say Shechter, the lights
went out, can you please turn them on?
Says the Rama, the same way that you're
allowed to do it at the beginning of
Shabbos that if I was mekabbel Shabbos, early
I'm allowed to go to my neighbor and
ask them to turn the lights on, so
too says the Rama at the end of
Shabbos on the other end, if I decide
that I want to observe Shabbos longer than
I have to, I'm allowed to call somebody
else over to my house to do a
melachah that I myself would not be allowed
to do yet because I did not make
Havdalah. That is what the Rama makes the
extension, which seems like a natural extension from
what the Shulchan Aruch says. Along comes the
Levush. The Levush lives in the 1500s, same
time as the Beis Yosef and the Rama,
and he says no no no, before Shabbos
is not the same as after Shabbos, and
he makes a whole distinction. The bottom line
is the Rama says that it would be
the same. And the same way you're allowed
to ask before Shabbos, so too you are
allowed to ask at the end of Shabbos,
which now leads us to the next question,
which is what about when it comes to
Yom Tov Sheni? Would all of this apply
to Yom Tov Sheni as well or would
you say no, the halacha by Yom Tov
Sheni would be a completely different story? This
is a discussion that is had in the
Birkei Yosef. Birkei Yosef is the Chida, who
quotes two of the great Sefardish Gedolim who
disagreed about this point. I'm going to read
you what he says. Ben chutz la'aretz she'omed
be'eretz Yisrael. If you have somebody who is
a resident of chutz la'aretz but is spending
Yom Tov in eretz Yisrael. Katav haMaharikash. He
quotes from one of the Gedolim who said,
shemutar lo lomar le-ben eretz Yisrael sheya'aseh lo
melachah be-Yom Tov Sheni. He first quotes the
Maharikash who said just like by erev Shabbos
if I accepted Shabbos early I'd be allowed
to ask someone to do melachah for me,
so too here I'd be allowed to do
the same. On the other hand, he then
quotes other acharonim who say that that would
not be permissible and he says the Mahari
Molcho, I don't know who that is, but
he quotes him and if the Birkei Yosef
quotes him he must be someone important. So
he says, dacha devarav vehiskimu le'esor, and he
says that that would be something that we
would not permit, that would not be allowed
to be done on Yom Tov Sheni. Why?
Why should it be different? Why should we
distinguish between erev Shabbos and Yom Tov Sheni?
So that's a big question that you need
to think about. But it seems that the
consensus of the Gedolei HaPoskim. is that even
though when you make early Shabbos, you'd be
allowed to ask someone to do a melacha
for you that you would not be allowed
to do. And even though the Rama says
on the back end, you'd be allowed to
ask someone after Shabbos is over to do
melacha, even though it's still Shabbos for you.
When it comes to Yom Tov Sheini, it
would seem that you would not be allowed
to do that and it's not necessarily the
same. We don't say that these two situations
would be the same. This came up with
a major, major shaila when it was a
get that had to be performed on Yom
Tov Sheini. A get had to be written
on Yom Tov Sheini. Now, what does it
mean a get has to be written on
Yom Tov Sheini? Get divorced the next day.
What's the big deal? The answer is sometimes
you have a husband who's giving a very
difficult time and he's not prepared to give
his wife a get, Rachmana Litzlan, and he's
leaving her an agunah, and he says, well,
tomorrow morning I have a flight, I'm going
to the Netherlands and I'm never coming back.
And that's it, we're not going to find
him anymore. So, it's Yom Tov Sheini, we
have to figure out what to do, but
the problem is we don't really have the
ability to write the get because it's Yom
Tov Sheini for us. So can we have
a Ben Eretz Yisrael write a get for
us on Yom Tov Sheini when for us,
we are Bnei Chutz La'aretz but we're in
Eretz Yisrael now? We're observing the second day
of Yom Tov. Would we be allowed to
do that or perhaps not? That's a major,
major interesting discussion in the poskim about that.
But the bottom line is that it would
seem that the consensus would be that you
would not be allowed to ask someone on
Yom Tov Sheini to do melacha for you
unless Rav Shlomo Zalman writes unless it's a
major makom tzorech, unless it's a major, major
emergency, something really important that needs to be
done, makom mitzvah. But outside of that, it
would seem that this is something that is
certainly not advisable and certainly not something that
we would encourage people to be involved with.
The last thing that we don't have enough
time to talk about is if I'm machmir
on a Shabbos and I decide that I
don't want to do opening bottles or something
like that carrying the eiruv, would I be
allowed to ask somebody else to do it
on my behalf when I myself would not
do it? But we'll save that maybe.